le mardi et le samedi
mais attention je n'ai jamais fixé de
tokyo toujours des rectifications
d'antalis
notez bien qu albert einstein n'a pas
dit l'important est de toujours trouver
des réponses et ça va ça nous arrange
cela m'amène à partager ce soir avec
vous les conclusions d'une étude que
j'ai rigoureusement menée grâce à
laquelle j'ai modéliser le constat
suivant
dans la vie il y a deux types de
personnes celles qui se posent beaucoup
de questions et celle qui privilégie une
approche plus pragmatique des choses et
là où cette étude nous intéresse ce soir
c'est qu'elle a révélé que
statistiquement les gens qui se posent
beaucoup de questions regarde plus de
tadjiks tous les autres alors moi je
fais partie de ceux qui se posent
beaucoup de questions donc internet le
sel est à chaque fois sur youtube
les algorithmes me propose de nouveaux
lieux de nouveaux tedx dans les
suggestions de vidéos là donc qu'est-ce
que je fais là bas je clique je clique
encore et encore jusqu'à très tard le
soir
jab revin si ma soif de connaissances
grâce au talent x bon je veux dire que
parfois en même temps que j'écoute je
joue humble gommer ce terminator
vous connaissez bubble gum exterminator
c'est un jeu flash avec des lapins qui
font plein de bulle de chewing gum
il faut cliquer dessus le plus vite
possible pour le faire exploser assez
profondément satisfaisant ouais donc au
final je ne sais pas auquel des deux je
suis le plus dépendantes le
questionnement sur le sens de la vie
grâce à youtube où le jeu flash mais
d'après mon étude les deux vont bien
ensemble
ben c'est scientifique c'est on se vide
la tête d'un côté on cela remplit de
l'autre c'est c'est des neurosciences
tout simplement
donc les gens qui se posent beaucoup de
questions regard plus de tadjiks que les
autres par contre on retrouve plus les
pragmatiques sur scène par exemple heidi
nous a parlé tout à l'heure de son
métier de glaciologues alors plus qu'un
métier d'ailleurs c'est une véritable
passion pour l étude des glaciers bon le
seul truc un peu dommage c'est que sa
passion est en train de faire
mais qu'à cela ne tienne les glaces ifs
elle va en articles par des études sur
le terrain ça glisse un peu elle y va
ans qui s'est facilement cette
détermination à aller droit au but ce
pragmatisme
moi c'est pas comme ça que je fonctionne
moi je m'interroge je prends des chemins
détournés de questionnements tiens au
fait si je rencontre michelle obama par
hasard lors d'une balade sur la dune du
pilat plus pour elle bien il raconté la
dépendance au chocolat aurait-elle pour
origine une vie antérieure chez les
aztèques qui aurait mal tourné
voilà je m'interroge et j'aboutis
souvent à la même conclusion
bubble gum exterminator donc c'est vrai
que niveau pragmatisme je ne suis pas
tout à fait au top mais bon ils m'ont
invité quand même et je suis ravi d'être
là ce soir surtout comme intervenant sur
ce texte j'ai découvert quelque chose
que vous ne voyez pas les coulisses d'un
tel x et je vais tout vous raconter
quand on intervient sur un thé dixons se
fait coacher
alors attention ne vous fourvoyez pas
comme certains dans la critique facile
le coaching tedx ça n'est pas du
formatage c'est bien plus subtil que ça
on est coach et pour que notre
présentation reste naturel mais pas trop
à larache non plus c'est à dire qu'il
faut que ce soit un naturel travailler
mais pas à théâtraliser c'est subtil
vous savez c'est un peu comme quand on
dit aux femmes qu'elles sont tellement
plus belle au naturel sans artifice
superficielles par contre les poils non
wallon les poils c'est indécent les
poils c'est du naturel pas assez
travaillé vous voyez là
la subtilité alors mais c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué en tant que femme cette
histoire de poils sa touche notre
rapport à notre corps et notre féminité
ça peut même prendre une dimension
militante voire politique
oui les poils on peut en faire un débat
politique si si on n'a que ça à
pour ou contre le port des poils dans
les lieux publics
l'épilation n'est-elle pas un symbole de
soumission alors moi face à ces tous et
dilemme existentiel j'ai trouvé la
solution comme ça je ne me pose plus la
question
je m'épile je m'épile mais une seule
jambe
c'est extrêmement libérateur c'est
tellement libérateur que j'ai décidé de
lancer mon propre mouvement dans le cas
dans la lignée des précédents grands
mouvements de libération de la femme
mouvement que j'ai appelé me poilus
milices alors ça marche avec les jambes
mais ça marche aussi avec les aisselles
et avec le maillot vous l'aviez pas de
photos là comme attendait c'est interdit
que c'est pas la fête du slip
ce nouveau mouvement que je lançais
aussi l'occasion pour moi deux et
prendre pleinement ma place de leader
afin que les femmes comme les hommes
d'ailleurs suivre mon exemple pour se
libérer des dictats de la société à
moitié du monde eh oui sarah nous a
parlé tout à l'heure des conclusions de
sa thèse comme quoi le leadership est
autant masculins que féminins
donc on le sait le leadership n'a pas de
sexe mais le leadership at il des points
ça on ne sait toujours pas bon
évidemment ce tadic n'est pas interdite
comme les autres c'est un tadic oui mais
ils sont quand même invité des hommes
histoire de respecter à peu près la
parité ou à peu près et oh ça va deux
hommes pour six femmes
bon alors il se trouve que de manière
tout à fait fortuite
ce sont les deux hommes qui conclut
chacune des deux parties
alors ça c'est un hasard enfin vraiment
j'en ai parlé avec les organisateurs ce
n'est pas du tout une volonté que les
hommes aient le dernier mot
c'est juste que bon bah ça se goupille
et bien comme ça
c'est terrible a écouté j'ai beau
travailler sur moi j'ai beau essayer
d'équilibrer mon féminin et masculin
intérieur sacré il ya toujours au moins
une par féministe enragée et mesquines
qui voient le mal partout
surtout que l'homme qui a conclu la
première partie c'est thomas qui nous a
parlé de cyber harcèlement lui qui en
est victime tout ça parce qu'il est un
homme qui véhiculent des messages
féministe alors le témoignage de thomas
est essentiel parce que quand on n'a pas
vécu de harcèlement soi même on ne sait
pas la violence que ça peut représenter
au quotidien et là thomas nous a donné
des exemples concrets notamment
l'exemple des pizzas que ses harceleurs
commandait pour lui chaque soir bah moi
c'est plutôt sympa je suis là ça l'a pas
avoir compris tout de suite un oui mais
parce qu'elle n'était pas payé ses
pizzas en parlant de pizzas quand on
intervient sur un tas d'il ya deux
choses très importantes à garder en tête
il ya le why why
pourquoi pourquoi on est sur scène
pourquoi on parle dans ce micro qu'est
ce qui nous fait vibrer oui je vibre oui
parce que vous voyez les messages
passent carrément mieux quand on les
exprime avec le corps donc il ya le why
et ya le tchèque le web qu'on peut
traduire en français par plats à
emporter mais c'est tout de suite
beaucoup moins classe alors les take
away c'est des trucs qu'on doit mettre
dans notre conférence et que vous allez
ramener chez vous pour passer à l'action
bon moi je vous parlerai de mon moi et
tout à l'heure mais je peux trop de take
away donc je vous propose vous rentrez
chez vous vous passez par la pizzeria
vous prenez trois margarita emporté
j'aurai ainsi rempli ma mission
ensemble on va changer le monde une
pizza à la fois bon vous l'avez compris
je pense je suis vraiment une grande fan
des tadjiks
mais je garde à l'esprit critique
néanmoins c'est important et si je peux
me permettre une critique constructive
des tadjiks
[Musique]
tout va bien ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
juste que nos côtes sont pas mal insisté
sur l'importance de silence
appuyez bien placé celui-là n'était
peut-être pas si bien placé que ça et
pas assez appuyé je pense pas il faut
que la présentation respire vous
comprenez je disais donc si je peux me
permettre une critique constructive des
tadjiks
je trouve que 12 minutes maximum 17 pour
chaque conférence où c'est un peu long
surtout avec tous les silences qu'il
faut mettre dedans
donc je lave ou certains soirs seul face
à mon écran d'ordinateur
il m'arrive de trahir les tedx quand
j'ai besoin d'aller au coeur des choses
de retrouver l'essence pure des concepts
clés de notre société
je regarde un autre genre de vidéos qui
enrichissent internet vous avez le genre
de documentaire en version carrés avec
des énormes sous titres et qui dure
trois voire quatre minutes et qui se met
en route tout seul sur les réseaux
sociaux d'eau qu'on fait on choisit même
pas ce qu'on regarde là c'est percutant
là on va droit au but et on change en
profondeur la vie des gens qui regardent
je me souviens comme ça un jour j'avais
vu la vidéo d'une famille qui était
passé au zéro déchet et il montrait le
volume de leurs déchets en une année ça
tenait dans une petit jard dans laquelle
il y avait notamment un pansement
usagers de leur enfant était un joueur
rentrait de l'école avec ce pansement et
il n'avait pas su le recycler le
pansement par enfant eh bien figurez
vous que cette vidéo de quatre minutes a
eu un très fort impact sur moi puisque
depuis bon je suis pas tout à fait passé
au zéro déchet même si je fais de mon
mieux
par contre à chaque fois que je mets un
pansement à l'un de mes enfants
j'y pense à chaque fois surtout que j'ai
deux enfants ils sont encore assez jeune
donc quand je met un pansement alain ça
n'aura jamais l'autre se met subitement
à pleurer il me montre une vieille
égratignures cicatriser cinq mois plus
tôt mais voir son frère avec un
pansement et pas lui
ravi de son ancienne douleur et il est
visiblement en grande souffrance
donc le lui mais a lui aussi un
pansement voilà donc de pansements pour
un bobo
je culpabilise doublement par rapport à
mon empreinte écologique mais
heureusement que l'état dit que ce sont
là pour rattraper le coup car j'ai
trouvé la solution grâce un clara clara
architectes nous a parlé tout à l'heure
de mettre en lien les déchets de la
construction avec les habitat dégradé et
si ça c'est pas du pragmatisme et bien
moi je me suis inspiré de cette démarche
dans le cadre de la rénovation de mon
appartement je recycle à présent les
pansements envisagée pour réparer les
joints tous pourris de ma salle de bain
la loi vous voyez c'est un exemple
concret on voit tout de suite l'impact
des tedx sur notre quotidien et surtout
pour la préservation de l'environnement
grâce à toutes ces bonnes idées qui
valent la peine d'être partagée
en conclusion il est temps pour moi de
vous partager mon pourquoi attention ça
va devenir très spirituel grâce à ma
tendance ou questionnements au compulsif
j'ai compris pas mal de choses de la vie
et j'ai souvent eu besoin d tedx pour me
les enseigner mais parfois même et adx
ne suffisent plus dans ces moments-là il
m'arrive alors d'engager des
conversations directement avec les anges
j'ai prévenu que ça d'être très
spirituel alors les anges pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas c'est tout un concept
qui stipule que quand on a une question
eh bien il suffit de demander
alors moi avec toutes les questions que
je me pose cette démarche de poser mes
questions directement à l'univers avec
des anges comme messager ça me plaît
alors certains vont peut-être s'imaginer
que j'entends des voix dans ma tête
pas du tout même si quand on y pense
jeanne d'arc était un excellent modèle
de leadership au féminin
non je parle d'autre chose
j'ai bel et bien des voix dans ma tête
j'en ai d'ailleurs beaucoup vous savez
le genre de pensées conditionné qui
tourne pas mal en rond qui s'inquiètent
du futur qui ressassent le passé qu'ils
seraient allés cover trois semaines pour
essayer de leur donner une tournure un
peu différente
vous voyez le genre je pense pas être la
seule non mais j'ai une manière très
simple de faire la différence entre ces
voix dans ma tête et la voix inspirante
de mésanges les anges quand je leur pose
mes questions et que j'entends leurs
réponses le plus souvent ils se foutent
de ma gueule
alors avec beaucoup d'amour mais
visiblement toutes mes questions la
salle effet beaucoup marré c'est comme
ça que je sais que ce ne sont pas juste
des voix dans ma tête
l'amour et l'humour l'humour ça ne sert
pas à se moquer ou alors seulement de
soi-même
ça ne sert pas à humilier rabaisser
harceler l'humour ça ne sert pas non
plus à montre
la finesse intellectuelle de nos jeux de
mots puisqu'au fond entre nous rien
n'est plus efficace et plus universel
qu'une bonne vieille d'akrout non
l'humour
selon moi c'est observer la même chose
mais d'un autre point de vue si vous
êtes athée si les anges n'ont pas de
place dans vos croyances
vous pouvez remplacer le concept ange
pas reprendre de la hauteur
c'est ça mon pourquoi prendre de la
hauteur
créer un décalage s'élever à un instant
au dessus des pensées conditionnait qui
tourne pas mal en rond l'humour ça n'est
pas se voiler la face sur les problèmes
du monde on rigole un beau coup et on
n'y pense plus l'humour ça n'est pas une
fuite
c'est une connexion à autre chose je
vais même jusqu'à parler de reconnexion
alors s'il nous arrive de nous
identifier à nos réalisations à nos
possessions à notre prestige ou même à
notre prétendue médiocrité ou à notre
souffrance
s'il nous arrive de penser qu'une
personne est plus remarquable qu une
autre c'est peut-être le bon moment de
prendre de la hauteur par exemple en y
mettant de l'humour ou quand vraiment ça
n'est pas drôle du tout en y mettant de
l'amour en accueillons en écoutant
l'esprit ouvert à l'autre et à soi-même
comme ceux que vous public est venu
faire ce soir avec toute votre
bienveillance et gardons bien en tête
que les anges ont beau trouvé ça très
drôle toutes nos questions là ils ne
peuvent pas faire de conférences tedx
pas plus qu'ils le peuvent regarder de
tedx jusqu'à très tard le soir en jouant
bas de gamme exterminator alors prenons
pleinement notre place d'êtres humains
connectés mais un carnet que nous soyons
plutôt du genre pragmatique ou du genre
à nous poser beaucoup de questions voire
un peu trop
je conclurai avec un message clé ce que
c'est toujours bien d'avoir un message
clé dans un tas dicks soyons inspiré et
alors nous serons inspirant tel un
phénix incarner au quotidien merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]